Tim Cook just said that nine million
developers were added to the apple
ecosystem this year how hard is it to
find a good Apple Developer extremely
hard I think most companies like ours
are really focused on training people
who are previously experts in a
different platform to be experts in iOS
and Android when I was the chief
technology officer of Facebook we
actually started a formal set of classes
where engineers could attend for a sort
of an intensive handful week period
where they would actually learn android
and iOS development there's so much
demand for these products and just due
to the fact that the iPhone was lunch in
2007 I mean there can only be so many
experts in that period of time so how
many so you've given the facebook
experience I wonder how much of a heads
up how much help Apple gives in terms of
stories saying this is our direction
behind the scenes I mean I know
Facebook's relationship with Apple is
kind of difficult there for a while you
know not a lot of direction I mean
simply because Apple is such a
notoriously secretive company and I
think in at the moment they start
talking to partners the moment we're all
talking about it prior to the speech
that sound even with I wouldn't say it
was better or worse at a large company
they're just a very very you know close
company you'll notice you know there'll
be a handful of companies that worked
with them on the product launches but
you know those you know number in the
four or five companies for her release
and so
you know we don't get a lot of direction
but we're usually pretty happy with the
results I just really want to know how
you get to be one of those companies
that worked with apple on the release of
a nap um you know I can speak from
personal experience when the Facebook
was integrated into iOS 7 it was largely
due to sort of you know high-level
discussions about one of the company's
work more closely together on the
smaller releases they tend to work with
sort of independent software vendors
smaller shops you know a lot of game
companies I met her yeah i mean just
companies i believe that just Apple
employees respect due to the quality of
their products and you know feel like
they can trust now Craig federighi the
senior vice president of software
engineering is on stage right now he's
talking about OS 10 the desktop
operating system you know how important
is advancement and improvement in the
desktop given that mobile is where the
growth is happening Joe it's huge you
really you can't ignore the desktop yes
mobile is very very hot but like
millions and millions of us go to work
each day and we're not all staring at
smartphones like I work at a pretty tech
forward company and I have an imac I'm
not sitting there on an iPad with a
keyboard it's really important because
at this point you know power is still
your limiting factor when it comes to to
getting things done on a sort of
enterprise level and that's power both
in terms of processing power and also
electricity so if you have an
unconnected untethered device you're
probably not gonna have as much battery
life as you would well you have any
infinite matter left you're plugged in
but also just the ability to run big
apps like Photoshop and some of the
analytics programs that we use it
I was a line that every producer and
every editor who ever edited the words
the pc is dead did it on a pc that's not
the case I wonder particular your joke
because i know that you see sort of more
gadgets than your average human okay you
know i was talking to a friend as a
contractor visiting he said that he went
to the show in las vegas and so all
these phone controlled locks and
security cameras and and dimmable leds
and stuff all over the home it is is
that stuff really exploding right now
and why um it's exploding from a company
perspective I think we have yet to see
wide like widespread adoption of it the
problem is that it's easy for you to go
to the store and pick up a new cell
phone it's not as easy to pick up a new
light switch you have to get that
installed Apple has officially unveiled
the next generation of their desktop
operating system and it is indeed Paul
Yosemite somebody owes me five bucks you
were right someone owes it goes out of
that bad come on it's a big time it's
also a better California redwood it
could have been any number exert well
there's a el capitan is hanging right in
there but how important is this next
generation of the desktop operating
system going to be for you um Brett you
know given that you're you're really
working on how people work at home and
work you know I think I think there's
two things that we think about you know
one is that even though the pc is
shrinking relative to the tablet and
smartphone it's still extremely
important and because of that i think
that apple's in a unique position
because their laptops are well regarded
outpacing the sales and most vendors
laptops you know even though window
still has dominant market share pcs and
i think they're in an entry position
with developers where microsoft's
relationship developers is wayne
dramatically over the past few years I
think there's an opportunity to really
take all the energy they have around iOS
development and channel that towards
their their desktop operating system and
if like me you believe the products like
cliff should work seamlessly across
these devices I'd rather work with Apple
because I already work with them and I
think that's a really interesting
strategic position to be in